depuis six ans déjà le bâtiment des
sciences de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines accueille un
groupe de recherche en physique bien
pointues le groupe d'étude de la matière
condensée gmac
c'est la recherche fondamentale c'est
pour comprendre la physique de la base
pour après manipuler les matériaux pour
des applications spécifiques
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un bouton
maintenant que tous les équipements sont
pleinement opérationnelles
l'université a réuni hier des
scientifiques concernés par ces
recherches pour inaugurer son
laboratoire aux outils ultra
perfectionnés en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le laboratoire était à
l'origine sur deux sites
un site qui étaient ici sur l'université
de versailles est un site qui était à
meudon et donc ces deux ces deux sites
ont été regroupés en un laboratoire ici
donc il ya eu de nouveaux locaux et
toutes les expériences ont été
regroupées ici sur le site de versailles
ils sont 34 permanent en blouse blanche
à faire de la recherche ici des machines
impressionnantes comme celle ci pour
recréer des diamants ou celle ci dont il
n'existe qu'un seul autre exemplaire en
france disponible à la recherche 1600 m²
de locaux investis par les cinq équipes
de recherche est ouvert aux étudiants
les plus curieux dont vous voyez on est
au milieu de l'université c'est à dire
qu'il ya des amphis des étudiants qui
circulent autour du laboratoire
régulièrement donc il ya une très forte
interaction entre les chercheurs du
laboratoire et les étudiants de
l'université
créée en 1991 l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin compte dix-huit
mille étudiants répartis sur cinq campus